YURI GRINSHTEYN: When you run
applications in production,
you need to monitor the
infrastructure they run on.
You also need to measure the
golden signals of application
health like error
rates and latency.
Today I'm going to show you
how to instrument your service
to expose application-specific
telemetry with Prometheus
and how to configure Google's
Manage Prometheus service
to ingest those metrics.
I'm Yuri, an SRE at Google.
Welcome back to "Engineering for
Reliability with Google Cloud."
Last time, we started using
Google's managed service
for Prometheus by replacing
the Prometheus image
with Google's forked image.
That enabled ingesting
Prometheus metrics
into the managed back end and
querying them using PromQL.
Those metrics were then also
available in Cloud Monitoring.
And you can start using them in
charts, dashboards, and alerts.
That was enough to start
collecting infrastructure
metrics from our cluster.
Today, we're going to
go two steps further.
I'm going to show you how
to instrument your service
to expose telemetry and
how to configure Prometheus
to ingest those metrics.
We'll do that by setting up
Managed Prometheus Collection,
a zero-management way to
run Prometheus and the way
to go if you're
new to Prometheus
or setting up a new cluster.
All right, let's get into it.
The first step is to
instrument our service itself
to expose a dedicated
endpoint that Prometheus
can use to scrape for metrics.
We covered this in our previous
episode on custom metrics.
But let's have a quick look
at an example in Python.
We'll of course link to the full
sample in the episode notes.
This is an example of
Python Flask app that
just has a basic home page.
Let's walk through
the code together.
First, import the
necessary modules.
Then define the metrics
you want to capture.
In this example,
we're going to track
total requests, failed requests,
and a latency distribution.
We're going to use a
Decorator to time how long it
takes to load a specific route.
And we can increment
the counters as needed.
Finally, we specify the endpoint
where Prometheus metrics
should be exposed.
Now we can see the data
on this /metrics endpoint.
We're now ready to move
on to the second step
and configure Prometheus to
collect and ingest this data.
Let's start by verifying that
our application is ready to be
monitored by Prometheus.
We can use port forwarding
to confirm that it's exposing
Prometheus metrics on
the /metrics endpoint.
In order to get our application
monitored by Managed Prometheus
collection, we'll
need to do two things.
First, we'll use
this gcloud command
to install Managed
Prometheus in our cluster.
Note that you can do this using
kubectl if your cluster is not
running in GKE.
At this point, we can confirm
that infrastructure collection
is working by querying metrics
that the Managed Prometheus
collector is ingesting
about itself, for example.
Now, we're ready to get
our application monitored
by creating a new pod
monitoring resource.
The selector specifies
which pods to monitor
based on label value.
And the endpoints specify
where to scrape for metrics.
As we saw before, our
application is exposing
Prometheus metrics on the
/metrics endpoint on port 8080,
which is called metrics in
a deployment configuration.
Once that's applied,
let's run a query
to confirm that application
metrics are being ingested.
And there we are.
We can also query this
metrics in Metrics Explorer
simply by searching
for it like this.
And that's how you can
instrument your application
for Prometheus Monitoring and
have its metrics be collected
and ingested by the Google
managed service for Prometheus.
Thanks so much for
watching today.
We learned how to instrument
your application for Prometheus
monitoring and how to
configure Google's managed
service for Prometheus
to collect those metrics.
Next time, we'll
have a look at how
to migrate an
existing Prometheus
deployment to the managed
service for Prometheus.
And if you have any
other topics you'd
like me to cover,
please comment below.
Don't forget to like and
subscribe to never miss out
on more "Engineering for
Reliability with Google Cloud."
See you soon.